we've all thought about disasters
imagine massive floods fires or a meteor
suddenly crashing into earth but what
happens when the destruction comes
quietly and suddenly with the dawning of
a new day over the next 24 hours the
world as we know it will crumble and
something strange and terrible will rise
to take its place what will that look
like who will try to rise to the
occasion and help and who will cower in
the dark what happens to the people
around the world in the first 24 hours
after day breaks let's find out hour one
it's 6 a.m on a farm in kansas and the
land is just beginning to wake up the
farmer and his wife and children are
still sleeping waiting for the cry of
their rooster to tell them that it's
time to start the day the cows are
grazing in the open field letting out
the occasional half-hearted moo but
they're still a bit too sleepy to give
it their all the pigs snort restlessly
in the barn feeling breakfast time
approaching the rooster proud and
stately hops onto the roof of the
chicken coop surveying his domain he
tilts his head back and lets out a
mighty crow cockadoodle the sound
catches in his throat as something
strange begins to happen his beak
softens like wax dripping from a lit
candle he drops to the ground with a
soft plop as his mighty wake-up call
fades to a gurgle there is something
wrong this morning something truly
deeply wrong if the rooster were capable
of complex thought he would be terrified
instead he is just melting along with
the hens the cows and the pigs all
dripping onto the grass as the faint
light of mourning changes them inside
the farmhouse the family begins to
scream hour two an hour later in new
york city the city that never sleeps
gets a rude awakening no one can be sure
when exactly the chaos broke out but all
of a sudden people in their little
apartments wake up to the sound of
masses of other people calling out for
help of the thunderous footsteps of
crowds tearing through the streets
and then of a strange gurgling sound
that replaces the bedlam a young woman
throws open her blackout curtains to get
a better look and finds herself melting
along with them across town a landlord
knocks on his tenant's door demanding
some overdue rent but there is no answer
only the slop of something oozing across
the floor inside security footage of
times square catches an eerie sight
masses of molten flesh spreading across
the streets the masses of tourists that
were gathered there only hours before
melted together into something else
bathed in the neon glow of the
billboards and lights of the city hour
three on the other side of the world in
canberra australia a group of college
students is camping in the wilderness
while the united states is waking up to
a horror show they are sleeping soundly
in their tents beneath the light of the
moon well except for one of them who had
decided to take his sleeping bag outside
and sleep under the stars that would
have been a lovely idea except for the
fact that all sunlight including that
which reflected off the moon has become
quite destructive to the human body to
all living things in fact his melted
form sloshes around inside the sleeping
bag trying to regain some semblance of
its original shape inside their tent his
friends are still themselves shielded
remarkably well from the light by the
thick canvas that is until one of them
gets up to go to the bathroom and unzips
the front of the tent his mouth is
already useless by the time he thinks to
scream and the moonlight floods inside
and covers the group in a silvery glow
it doesn't take long for them to meet
the same fate as their friend outside
melting together into one massive entity
they had hoped this camping trip would
bring them closer together and
well it did our four
meanwhile a speleologist is deep in the
bowels of a cave in tianjiang that she
has been studying completely unaware of
the terrors of the surface she's taking
samples dictating notes to her research
assistant and keeping an eye out for
bats when suddenly she receives a
communication from one of the members of
her research team up above the
technology they use only allows for
short text messages that can be
transmitted through the layers of soil
and rock all around but this warning
needs only a few words don't come up
not
safe the words send a chill upper spine
what could possibly be happening that's
more dangerous than being down here she
writes back asking for clarification but
receives none through the dark tunnels
illuminated only by a few headlamps she
thinks she can hear the echo of a scream
hour five those that are still safe and
have managed to hold on to their
identities and forms have noticed yet
another threat in addition to whatever
the light is doing all around the world
planes are dropping from the sky their
pilots and crews transformed into
something incapable of flying an
aircraft airplanes that were in route to
their various destinations thousands of
them going in every direction imaginable
are now plummeting towards the ground
crashing into the ocean or in some
especially unlucky cases landing on
buildings that still have survivors
inside it's a truly brutal bit of irony
to escape the sun's terrible rays and
find some small sanctuary only to have
an airplane fall out of the sky and
destroy it all hour six over at the scp
foundation everyone is on high alert
trying to categorize what is happening
and find a way to stop it but how do you
contain an anomaly when that anomaly is
the sun itself in the meantime the o5
council retreats to a specialized
underground bunker constructed
especially for this kind of dire
scenario outfitted with beds reading
materials and enough supplies to keep
them alive for several years as long as
no one hogs the snacks as the rest of
the foundation staff scramble to find a
solution before the rest of the earth's
population is reduced to goo the
anomalies contained throughout the
various sites begin to take notice
scp-999 oozes frantically around its
site hugging and nuzzling anyone it can
get close to it doesn't fully understand
what is going on but it can tell that
everyone is quite upset and frightened
by something and it wants to help them
feel better other anomalies have a less
charitable approach
scp-173 takes advantage of the chaos to
escape containment snapping a few necks
on its way out just for fun after all
everyone's eyes are otherwise occupied
because it is not made from any organic
material it is immune to the effects of
the sun and makes its way outside to
explore the pandemonium research staff
pass by
scp-682's containment chamber can hear
the giant beast chuckling to itself a
sickening choking sound as it laughs at
the fall of humanity finally
its size one scientist peeking through
the observation window swears that the
hard to destroy reptile is smiling
before one of his colleagues ushers him
down the hall away from the monster's
celebration
scp-507 appears in the hall with a pop
back from another one of his involuntary
interdimensional voyages whoa where's
the fire he asks taking in the hysteria
around him
did
something get out a bit of unease creeps
into his voice no shouts a passing guard
it's what's trying to get in
god i have the worst timing 507 groans
hour seven back in the realm of
civilians newscasters hop on to
broadcast from studios devoid of natural
light unsure if there are any survivors
left to hear their messages one
television personality forces his usual
bright smile staring down the barrel of
the camera with barely concealed tears
in his eyes he can't let his smile crack
can't let himself break down if he lets
himself cry
really cry he's scared he won't be able
to stop please
remain calm he reads off the
teleprompter as a production assistant
sobs into the shoulder of the camera
operator experts are working to
determine what is going on in the
meantime please follow these
instructions to ensure your safety and
that of your loved ones
do not go outside unless you are covered
in proper equipment to shield yourself
from the sun or moon block all sources
of natural light in your residence do
not attempt to interact with those who
have been affected by this disaster do
not touch them do not let them into your
home do not speak to them again please
remain calm help is on the way he
doesn't know if the words are true he
only knows that it's his responsibility
to give the people hope something
familiar they can turn to when nothing
makes sense the camera switches off he
covers his face and lets the tears loose
hour eight in spite of the pleas from
newscasters people are very much
panicking how could they not
everything's descended into absolute
mayhem and it's only been eight hours
since it all began unfortunately where
there is panic there's someone trying to
make a quick buck off of their fellow
man even more unfortunately the internet
is still up and running so far and with
survivors taking to social media to live
tweet their experiences and post as much
as they can on instagram facebook and
anywhere else they can reach out for
help it is the perfect environment for
scammers a twitter thread goes viral
claiming that wrapping oneself in
aluminum foil will protect against the
effects of the light facebook posts
circulate hawking all sorts of natural
remedies and super sunscreens from
essential oil blends to bacon grease a
fraudulent gofundme page pops up
claiming to belong to a climate
scientist raising money for a ray gun
that will reverse the damage done to the
earth's atmosphere which he cites as the
cause of the destruction hour nine not
all the information circulating online
is false however a video is posted on
tick tock with the caption these mofos
can talk featuring video of a teenage
boy cowering in a dark room as one of
the formerly human flesh creatures moves
around outside the door after a moment
or two of silence a garbled voice calls
out to him brian
come outside please come out into the
sun
i
miss you the video's comments are filled
with other users sharing similar
experiences saying it talked just like
my boyfriend it barked like a dog or
even it was singing my favorite ariana
grande song similar videos pop up in the
wake of this first recording urging
survivors to ignore the voices no matter
who they seem like they belong to
our ten while some people are using the
internet to spread helpful information
on the nature of the events outside
others have ruled out rational
explanations entirely claiming that this
is divine punishment for the sins of
mankind or the matrix finally collapsing
in on itself others deny that the
horrible events are even happening at
all an infamously contrarian livestream
personality logs on from his insulated
basement growing to his viewers that
none of this is actually happening it's
all a ploy to keep us complacent and
under government control ask yourself
why don't they want us going outside so
we don't see what they're really up to
as commenters try desperately to change
his mind he doubles down you're all just
a bunch of sheeple papa he laughs look
i'll show you there's nothing to worry
about he carries his laptop upstairs
with him and steps outside onto the
sidewalk in his computer screen he can
see the video feed of his own face
beginning to droop and liquefy before he
can even feel it he tries to run back
inside away from the light but it's too
late his legs are already giving out the
viewers can only watch as their favorite
streamer dissolves in real time until
his now useless hands drop the laptop to
the ground where it breaks into pieces
and the stream goes dark hour 12. for
those who have survived this long at the
12 hour mark things are beginning to get
tense actually that would be an
understatement tensions have been
bubbling steadily for the past 12 hours
as people have melted into
unrecognizable waxy monsters exploded in
plane crashes and been traumatized to
within an inch of their lives now those
tensions are boiling over human beings
in a crisis can be a bit like crabs in a
bucket vicious and ready to tear each
other to pieces if they perceive that
they might be left behind when there is
a shortage of resources this selfish
fear and anger only gets worse hour 13.
there might not be a lack of food or
fresh water yet but there is another
resource that seems worth destroying
each other for darkness in a world where
light means death the only safe place is
in the dark but there are a limited
number of places that people can go in
rural areas families retreat to storm
cellars or the insides of empty grain
silos in cities underground parking
garages become hiding places and there
just isn't enough space there to go
around people erupt into physical fights
in these parking complexes punching and
shoving each other even attacking with
broken bottles and other improvised
weapons all to stake their claim over
this newfound territory even more
contentious are warehouses insulated
hiding places filled with all the
supplies that will soon start to dwindle
toilet paper canned goods soap and
bottled water these things just might be
worth killing for and many are already
prepared to do so hour 14. while the scp
foundation is busy trying to maintain
order and find a way to end this
catastrophic event other groups
dedicated to the anomalous are equally
busy the chaos insurgency attempt to
launch a sneak attack on site 19 while
its occupants are distracted however
their defenses against the sun prove
ineffective and they are melted before
they can so much as reach the site's
entrance inside the foundation staff
never even notice they have far too much
on their hands already other groups take
a less offensive approach prioritizing
safety members of the serpent's hand
escape to the interdimensional wanderers
library along with their families
settling in for the long haul and
preparing to make it their permanent
home as the earth burns they didn't want
it to end this way but they are not
going to stick around to be a part of it
all hour 18. not all people are turning
on each other even as things appear dire
the best thing anyone can do in a
horrible situation is to look for those
willing to extend a helping hand there
will always be people trying to look out
for others to put out the fires and
airlift people out of the flood waters
though this disaster seems anything but
natural the instinct to help is still
there for many doctors and nurses hole
up in hospitals blocking out the windows
with spare pairs of scrubs and whatever
else they can find to light proof the
building there they treat the wounded
that make it inside wrapping broken
bones and stitching up wounds as best
they can a few well-intentioned souls
even attempt to treat those changed by
the sun those things that barely look
human anymore no matter how hard they
try to arrange their soft bodies back
into their former shape it is too late
for them though there's nothing to be
done and no medical school in the world
could have prepared a doctor to heal
this hurt but what about the people who
aren't all the way gone the ones who
started to change but got inside in time
to slow or even stop the process
hospital staff treat the melting like an
infection amputating molten limbs or
attempting to clean and bandage them
unsure of what to do with a piece of
human body that no longer behaves like
flesh and bone they're able to save a
few people but far more are already
doomed by the time they make it inside
they disintegrate slowly but steadily
fading away on the operating table until
their warbling voices are urging the
doctors to follow them outside it
doesn't hurt they promise reaching out
with fleshy tentacles that were one's
hands it's hard to remember the
hippocratic oath when a monster is
trying to pull you into its grasp hour
20 while some are trying to help the
creatures created by the sun's wrath
others have been waiting for this moment
since they saw their very first zombie
movie to them this is an outbreak plain
and simple and it's the perfect chance
to suit up and play soldier they cloak
themselves in body armor and helmets
with dark tinted visors and grab
whatever weapons they can find grenades
firearms flamethrowers anything is fair
game at the end of the world a former
police officer and massive fan of
zombie-themed first-person shooters
takes to the streets staring down an
enormous mound of flesh made from dozens
of people melding together ropey
tentacles flailing and grasping for more
bodies to add to its mass he fires an
array of bullets into the thing but they
are absorbed into its surface swallowed
up inside he searches for weak points
for eyes a heart anything he can target
but he can't spot anything vulnerable
but he's not deterred he'll try fire
next he lights a homemade molotov
cocktail and hurls it at the beast
waiting for it to ignite and listening
for the sound of its painful cries but
nothing comes the cocktail explodes and
nearby debris catches on fire but the
ball of flesh doesn't react it just
continues to advance towards him making
its way down the street as if it has all
the time in the world
there's only one option left and it's
the riskiest one of all he pulls out a
grenade and pulls the pin throwing it
won't do he needs to run up and thrust
the grenade into the body of the monster
to blow it up from the inside he's going
to have to be quick he summons all the
stamina from his high school track and
field days and makes a mad sprint for
the creature holding the grenade out in
front of him eyes on the prize there is
nothing but the mission now the chance
to be a hero he is so singularly focused
on his task that he doesn't notice a
tentacle snaking along the ground toward
him until it loops around his feet
flipping him over until he's upside down
the force of the movement knocks his
helmet loose and it falls to the ground
he moves to shield his face with his
hands but it's useless the sunlight has
already found him he is already changing
becoming one with the very thing he
promised to destroy he stares up at the
mass with reverence just before his eyes
drop out of his head and reaches his
arms out to welcome the embrace by the
time the grenade detonates he can't
bring himself to care about it he can't
care about anything except being part of
the flesh hour 22 if individuals have a
tendency to blame each other in times of
strife then governments are even worse
surviving leaders of various countries
shivering in their bunkers and tearing
out their hair with stress begin to
convince themselves that this must be
some kind of active biological warfare
gone wrong nuclear testing some kind of
deadly gas
something surely ruination on this grand
of a scale must be man-made with no
other recourse they begin declaring war
on each other everyone pointing a finger
at someone else as no one is able to
take responsibility the threats the
denials and the rage escalate until
finally the north korean government
makes a decision that would seem
completely insane under any other
circumstances
they attempt to nuke the sun it's
irrational and it's ineffective of
course but it's the last gasp of a
species hurtling towards extinction one
final attempt to bring it all to an end
before it's all truly over hour 24 and
as the dust clears it becomes completely
apparent the old world is dead and a new
world for better or for much much worse
is born nothing will ever be the same
again
now go check out scp-001 when daybreak's
dr bright and when day breaks scp-035
for more of everyone's favorite
apocalypse